that's what I used to love being young
that hoes boring remember that do where
we live we even have a hose so I
remember going to somebody's house and
they had that hose and it was laying
down
y'all got DISA damn much water as you
want just coming out of this magic rope
oh dude I remember just putting that
thing straight into my dome hole one
time and just taking on as much as I
could my god I mean I was so I was just
camel DUP brah
I was just h2 algebras filled with that
aqua you know Ana Latinos call it that
agua and we in its water but they don't
know how to say it it's like wow wow
you're like now wow tur but that's where
we meet together and we teach each other
you know but I remember that man that
house hos boy just a magic ass rope that
came out from somewhere and it would had
that water in it and in summertime the
water tasted a little bit like the pipes
you get that hidden but I whoa or if you
were the first person to take a sip off
the hose after somebody turned it on
that person was a psychopath maybe I
don't know let's ask everyone yes yes
that person was because that that first
hit had that it was rust it was it
tasted like house had a little bit of
paint and it maybe a little bit of iron
supplements in there that first hit boy
if somebody just went straight off the
hose after somebody turned it on it was
always real hot and that we did I
wouldn't have that but I did my boy
Daniel that lived in our neighborhood
that was his big thing and he ended up
getting into drugs and alcohol and drugs
and he um
big thing was he liked to get that hot
hose hit that first one that one that
you know it tastes like a damn two years
of science class right up in that first
gulp
it'll make you [ __ ] you know it'll make
you bones
pretend like they don't know each other
that [ __ ] has got so many minerals and
stuff in it you know you have a dam you
get that first hit off the hose that hot
hose hit boy and Daniel would do it he
would do one and he go to the neighbors
and do another next thing you know he's
testing positive for phosphorus and for
you know boron and [ __ ] next thing you
know you know he'll he'll walk around a
room in the the the the the light bulbs
in a room will kind of turn and follow
him like he's all because that hot house
hit had different elements in it had
iron you know had all kind of stuff sun
under be a you know some stuck animal in
the pipe and Daniel just take that thing
to the dome boy he just just Huff a
weasel off that first head of hothouse
water and he was risky he was always
kind of a risky boy well thanks for
watching that video right there that was
a beautiful little segment I think but
of course i'm partisan to myself but you
can move on to another video right now
you can check on this video or on this
video that's two different options and
you can also subscribe to the channel
check on a new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribe subscribe